bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end votre émission dédiée à vos
loisirs et a ressorti au sommaire un
auteur et un illustrateur en volutes en
sont à l'origine d'un ouvrage destiné
aux enfants dans une ambiance de noël
leurs droits seront reversés à une
association
ce samedi l'association des amis de
raymond devos propose deux spectacles
pour petits et grands coups de pouce et
jeux de mots sont au programme
vous voulez mêler sport et découverte de
fontenay-le-fleury la cour royale de
dimanche est pour vous
trois parcours sont proposés musique
savante et burlesque de la commedia dell
arte c'est le savoureux mélange de jani
lane le nouveau spectacle de l'ensemble
janequin en résidence à la mairie à la
merise d'autres apps il sera sur scène
ce week-end un avant-goût préparé par
sephora mamani camille lambert loufoque
décalé et joyeuse
ziani est la dernière création
artistique de l'ensemble clément
janequin formé depuis 37 ans ils
répètent actuellement à la merise de
trappes
ce spectacle fidèle à l'esprit de la
troupe les tire son nom d'un compositeur
de la première moitié du xvième siècle
qu'il faut juste expliqué que le xvième
siècle et surtout la première moitié
d'une période
de liberté au fait on alors exprimé un
endroit d'écrire la musique comme on
veut surtout le droit de mettre en
musique des textes qui peuvent être
parfois très gris war on peut mettre en
musique ce qui vous entoure le chant des
oiseaux et clément janequin et des
compositeurs qui a réussi à faire la
synthèse de tous les courants musicaux
de l'époque en mai tandis que des choses
qui sont extrêmement colorés du madrigal
polyphonique mise en musique de la
commedia dell'arte associant tous les
arts
l'ensemble janequin a souhaité
moderniser et théâtralisée la mise en
scène du spectacle pour que celle ci
reste compréhensible car à l'époque le
principe du concert n'existe pas on
apprit particulier dans les tous les
instruments et d'épurer au maximum la
polyphonie pour que chaque personnage
garde son identité
des fois on s'amuse à imiter les
instruments pour le pour accompagner les
personnages et donc il ya six chanteurs
la des six personnages pour qu'ils
soient plus compromis est un opéra
interprété en vénitien du 16e siècle
totalement un cap et là sur scène 6ème
façon marx brothers
alternant rôle féminin et masculin car à
l'époque peu de femmes étaient autorisés
à vivre de la musique ce que j'ai essayé
moi donc là de construire c'est une
histoire à partir de madrigaux
différents voilà donc le défi était
effectivement d'avoir une histoire qui
se tiennent qui est chanté en italien
mais qu'en même temps que le public
français pouvait comprendre du début
jusqu'à la fin
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est très
visuel aussi c'est vrai c'est très
burlesque c'est prêt ça bouge beaucoup
enfin le monde c'était que visuellement
ça puisse le faire pour découvrir cette
création artistique burlesque et très
visuelle avait plus célèbres
contre-ténor 2010 l'idée vous à la
merise de trappes dans deux mois ce sera
la période préférée des enfants je parle
bien sûr de noël
cette période a inspiré véronique
barbotin pour son ouvrage petite
histoire au pied du sapin avec nous
aussi michel breton l'illustrateur des
histoires bonjour à tous les deux
bonjour les rues de barbotan ces petites
histoires tombe beaucoup tournent donc
autour de noël et de l'hiver pourquoi ce
choix
moi je trouve que la magie de noël elle
a pas d'âge j'ai toujours aimé de pied
du petit et je trouve que c'est un
moment magique pour les enfants et qu'
il faut continuer à faire perdurer sa
danse dans votre histoire est aussi une
forte présence de rambouillet de sa
forêt vous êtes vous-même rambo liten
c'était très important
oui parce que je pense qu'on a une
chance énorme ans vivant à rambouillet
de pouvoir rallier le fait d'être pas
loin de paris et pas loin de chartres et
en même temps d'avoir la chance d'avoir
une forêt d'avoir la campagne et c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'appréciable de
pouvoir profiter de tout ça il ya
toujours ce petit rapport au sec les
animaux la communion homme animal mais
parce que je trouve que pour les enfants
notamment
ça peut être un moment pour eux quand
ils ont des fois des difficultés de
communication avec où les adultes ou
selon leur âge des fois avec leurs
copains de pouvoir avoir des moments de
complicité avec l'animal c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui permet de rassembler
les enfants et les animaux sans problème
même sens par les gestes du regard ou du
geste j'ai toujours à chaque petite
histoire il ya aussi une petite
illustration et c'est vous seul pour
autant qui en est l'auteur qu'est ce qui
vous a inspiré et bien véronique m'a
enfin il ya quelques temps quelques mois
m'a proposé d'illustrer son livre elle
m'a envoyé ses textes et je les lui et
j'ai été très émue par la plupart de ces
histoires et ça m'a inspiré donc
j'essaie de trouver une cohérence entre
mais mes dessins et puis ces histoires
et je pense que j'y suis à peu près
parvenu parce que d'après ses dires il
ya une petite tendresse pour chaque
descente a l'impression dans le monde
des enfants
tout à fait mais je pense qu'entre en
nous on a tous encore une petite part
l'enfant
enfin - faisant passer le seul manquant
en tout cas c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
j'ai fait des nounours en particulier
sur la colle la photo de couverture et
on le voit aussi il ya beaucoup de de
simplicité pour permettre aussi à
l'enfant d'aller chercher par rapport à
l'espace que ça il fallait des feux à
led et les illustrations qui soit à la
fois représentatif du texte mais à la
fois qu'ils soient simples pas la peine
de chercher des complications et est ce
que c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est véronique barbotin qui est venu
nous former quand vous en est devenu
finalement à collaborer tous les deux
voilà moi il ya quelques années en fait
je suis tombé par hasard sur une carte
postale qui reprenait une des peintures
de michel où il y avait trois ours dont
deux pour lequel j'ai vraiment eu le
coup de coeur et je me suis dit faut
absolument que je trouve le peintre qui
dessinent et qui peint des ours parce
que je trouve que c'est quand même assez
rare et donc en fait j'ai découvert
qu'on était après l'association arts et
lettres à rambouillet tous les deux et
donc ça a été vraiment une occasion de
pouvoir mieux connaître son travail ce
qui fait pas que des ours loin de là
mais par rapport au projet que j'avais
de pouvoir faire un jour un livre pour
enfants illustré j'ai trouvé que c'était
vraiment l'illustrateur qui pouvait
comprendre justement la tendresse des
textes et puis le fait que chaque
histoire a une fin heureuse et michel en
fête a bien compris ce côté aussi
souhaite que tous finissent bien
il ya eu beaucoup d'échangés entre vous
finalement michel breton a toujours
trouvé le premier petit dessin qu'il
fallait
mon but quand même quelques échanges
m'enfin bon dans le principe il a
finalement pas huit ans des changes que
ça en fait j'ai retouché quelques
petites choses en fonction d'eux des
commentaires de véronique mais bon dans
l'ensemble c'était bien quand même
toujours que je peux voir ce qu'on était
à peu près sur la même longueur d'onde
oui parce qu'en fait du coup c'était
vraiment que des petites retouches à
faire mais déjà sur la couverture moi
j'ai eu le coup de coeur dès le départ
quoi c'était vraiment les ours que je
rêvais d'avoir sur la couverture et en
terme d'histoire c'est très très court
donc s'est adapté à partir de quel âge
c'est à partir de 6 ans il n'y a pas
d'âge au dessus parce que je pense que
on a vu qu'il y avait des parents et des
grands-parents qui l'avait lui au départ
pour pouvoir le lire après leurs enfants
mais finalement qu'elle est bien aimé
aussi pour eux et pour les plus jeunes
quand leurs parents laurier justement
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des histoires de
tailles différentes mais qui reste
courte pour ce soit facile à lire et
agréable il ya aussi une particularité
avec ce recueil parce que sur le
quatrième de couverture ce que les
lecteurs découvriront c'est vous que
vous avez choisi tous les deux de
reverser vos droits d'auteurs et
d'illustrateurs à enfants cancer santé
donc c'est une association qui finance
la recherche sur les cancers des enfants
c'est important pour vous tous à breton
oui quand véronique de genre bien
toujours quand véronique m'a proposé
donc d'illustrer elle m'a effectivement
parler de cette association est bon tout
de suite j'ai passé le bac pour dire
c'est la première fois que je fais est
l'illustration l'illustration de livres
et du fait que c'était aussi pour faire
une bonne action une bonne oeuvre j'ai
accepté tout de suite bien sûr mais il
faut aussi leur donner de bonnes actions
envers les enfants
oui parce que je pense que c'est un
sujet qui est pas ces traités en fait
sans tomber dans le côté triste des
choses s'il ya un constat il ya plus
qu'à contrer plus de 1700 enfants
parents qui sont atteints de leucémie ou
d'autres cancers et en fait on a
tendance encore aujourd'hui en france à
penser que ils sont moins nombreux que
ça et surtout qui guérissent tous et
c'est pas le cas et je pense que du coup
une association qui a pour vocation
d'aider à financer de la recherche sur
la leucémie et le cancer c'est vraiment
encore d'actualité en france pour
justement continuer à skis un meilleur
taux de guérison
donc petite histoire au pied du sapin
c'est apg comme édition à cause de ce
livre veroni barbotin vous saurez
présente ce dimanche au salon des
écrivains de rambouillet pour le
dédicacer donc si vous voulez découvrir
toute cette petite histoire
merci à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau pour nous présenter cet ouvrage
merci on termine cette page littérature
avec un autre rendez vous hebdomadaire
avec le pavé du canal cette semaine on
parle économie avec le monde et chloé la
désir infini de david cohen donc daniel
cohen ou déclinent tout l'historique de
la mise en place de la croissance et les
différents échanges commerciaux de la
préhistoire jusqu'à notre époque
contemporaine
donc il vient définir tous ces échanges
qui se sont mises en place et pour lui
les deux gros points 2
d'inflexion de l'histoire c'est surtout
la la création de l'agriculture avec son
explosion démographique et ensuite ça a
été la révolution industrielle et
scientifique
l'auteur se poser la question de quelle
sera la troisième révolution
copernicienne qui viendra vraiment
réformer notre mode économique de
fonctionnement donc l'auteur se prend
pour fins soit prendre principe du
modèle danois finalement comme solution
à cette question et surtout comme adage
est comme comme modèle de réflexion de
plus tôt la qualité que la quantité à
saint rémy les chevreuse ce week-end il
sera question de coup de pouce et deux
coups de coeur au trampoline de l'adar
l'association des dizaines de raymond
devos propose deux spectacles et pour en
parler nous recevons en plateau claude
haymoz quitter nos jours êtes membre
fondateur de l'association un des
membres fondateurs un des membres
fondateurs mais tout d'abord on parle de
trampoline pourquoi alors les
trampolines chacun sait ce que c'est
c'est ce sont des à gré sur lesquels on
saute il se trouve que raymond devos
quand il était plus jeune avait voulu au
gala des artistes présenté un numéro de
trampoline et pour ça il avait besoin de
s'entraîner et donc il l'avait fait
venir un trampoline dans sa propriété la
hiérarchie nalement le numéro n'a pas eu
lieu je crois qu'il s'est fait mal mais
cette idée de trampoline nous a plu
lorsqu'il a été question de trouver un
terme générique pour désigner le titre
de ce spectacle qui revient annuellement
parce que c'est joli cette image de
faire cette image faire sauter un
artiste jusqu'aux doigts à lécousse
voilà c'est l'idée du coup de pouce et
c'est vrai que là d'art donc
l'association des amis de raymond devos
qui a vu le jour en 2007 juste après
enfin un an après le décès de raymond
devos
a pour but d'une part avec son coup de
pouce de propulser de jeunes talents
qu'il aurait apprécié pour leur univers
pour la qualité de leur humour et puis
également de proposer au public saint
rémois des artistes confirmés soit des
artistes vraiment devos 1 présente
inconnu soit des artistes qu'ils
auraient connu qu'il aurait apprécié
s'il les avait connus pour leur univers
soit des artistes qui interprète ses
textes avec un talent particulier
justement au monde vous le disais nous a
quittés il ya maintenant neuf ans oui
c'était bien sûr un humoriste reconnu
les dettes c'est trampoline aussi c'est
le rire le jeu à travers le mot voilà
voilà
raymond devos avait souhaité que soit
créé une fondation raymond devos qui
existe et l'association des amis de
raymond devos est une des forces d'appui
de la fondation et c'est vrai que son
désir c'était de défendre l'humour et un
humour de qualité faut savoir que
raymond devos quand même
il a créé une sorte de d'humour qu'on ne
connaissait pas cet humour bien sûr qui
fonctionnait sur les maux qui débusque l
absurde mais cet humour aussi qui était
politique et et clownesque qui était un
raymond devos était un personnage
musicaux et donc la darse ouvre à tous
types de spectacles susceptibles de
correspondre à cet univers donc le rire
le coup de pouce cette année et les pour
marc plutôt les i avant d'en parler je
vous propose de regarder un extrait de
santé de son spectacle de l'étonnant
monsieur d'autres films
vraiment mais ça maintenant
now ladies and gentlemen mister d'outils
alors le visage de l'acteur parle
peut-être aux gens quand même parce
qu'il joue dans plus belle la vie oui
mais pourquoi vous la voyez choisi comme
coup de pouce alors nous l'avons
découvert au festival des deux fosses de
l'humour qui se tient tous les deux ans
à monet dans l'indre et loire et dans ce
festival
il a eu deux prix le prix du de veau
d'or et devos du jury du jeune public et
c'est un spectacle très visuel
époustouflant sur un rythme effréné
c'est l'histoire d'un personnage qui est
qui est un balayeur et ce personnage
c'est dallas curieux à sa curiosité je
ne vais pas vous dire comment
mais en tout cas il se trouve propulsé
dans son imaginaire il lui arrive des
tas de choses hallucinantes tu vas
revenir foetus dans le ventre de sa mère
et puis aussitôt après chevalier en
colères épiques bref c'est très loufoque
que c'est très lourd
c'est très visuel et ça correspond à ce
côté visuel que raymond devos aussi
avait il ya aussi le coup de coeur alors
l'acteur le plus connu du public
peut-être surtout sa voix parce qu'il
était dans le fou du roi de stéphane
bern s'il s'agit de vincent roca
vous pouvez me dire quelques mots
vincent roca vraiment bon je pense que
les gens qui ont écouté le fou du roi
entendent encore savoir et ses
chroniques qui était quand même des
monuments de l'agilité de 2 qui était
drôle spirituel vraiment voilà c'est un
c'est un monsieur qui a connu raymond
devos qui a eu un de veau d'or aussi au
festival de monnaie qui a eu le grand
prix de la raymond devos de la langue
française en 2011 et ce monsieur il a un
humour qui est dans ce spectacle
delirium tremens l'équivalent en mots je
dirais
de celui de marc pistolet dit dans la
seine on va dire il ya la mise en scène
et puis le jeu mou c'est vraiment assez
différent alors c'est pas ce point parce
que derrière marc pistolet dit il ya
quand même une histoire est derrière
vincent roca et son univers complètement
délirant au niveau des mots il y as
enfin c'est très construit mais voilà il
y a quand même sa présence ccnucc qui
est extraordinaire son contact avec le
public et ça ça ne se décrit pas sas
expérimente sur scène il faut le voir
alors pour découvrir ces deux artistes
direction l'espace jean renoir
merci claude unités d'être venu en
plateau pour nous parler des trampolines
de l'adar merci beaucoup de m'avoir
on continue sur cette ut week-end votre
émission dédiée aux loisirs aux sorties
avec la page cinéma les yeux d'elsa ont
eu un coup de coeur pour un documentaire
il s'appelle compostelle chemin de vie
hilali paysages magnifiques et
spiritualité cette semaine au cinéma les
yeux les halles le coup de coeur c'est
un coup de coeur du mois c'est le mois
du film documentaire le mois de novembre
et du coup on vous a programmé plein de
documentaires mais en particulier un qui
nous tenait à coeur
un film qui s'appelle compostelle le
chemin de la vie de freddie mouchard
compostelle le chemin de la vie c'est un
film que nous proposerons pendant quatre
semaines pendant le mois du film
documentaire mais aussi qui est
important pour nous parce que nous
recevons le réalisateur ce vendredi 6
novembre à 20h30
c'est un film qui vous parlera du chemin
de compostelle évidemment comme son nom
l'indiqué mais pas du tout comme un
chemin de prière ou comme un chemin
religieux il vous en parlera comme un
chemin spirituel
c'est un très très beau film qui
s'appuie vraiment sur les paysages sur
le trajet sur la longueur du trajet du
chemin de compostelle sur les preuves
physiques que ça peut représenter sans
jamais s'attarder trop sur des parcours
de personnes d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
vraiment d'acteur dans ce film le chemin
est le seul acteur puisqu'en fait tout
les randonneurs qui sont partie prenante
du film ne sont là qu'en voix off ne
sont que qu'entendu et jamais film est
très beau du coup très profond sur la
spiritualité associés aux chemins de
compostelle mais aussi et surtout sur la
randonnée et sur le fait de marcher et
sur ce que ça provoque autant
intérieurement que psychologiquement pas
physiquement que psychologiquement
voilà c'est donc un vrai vraiment une
très belle découverte
à découvrir tout au long du mois de
novembre au cinéma les yeux d'elsa et en
particulier le vendredi 6 novembre en
présence du réalisateur freddy mouchard
en espérant vous retrouver très nombreux
et bientôt merci on continue à parler
cinéma avec les films sortis cette
semaine alors ce qui vous a plu ou déplu
c'est au micro de camille lambert
c'est un film qui a été repris un thème
qui a été repris des tas de fois hélas
en avant c'est autre chose je trouvais
ça génial ça m'a beaucoup plu
c'est le thème c'est l'exode mais ce qui
me met vraiment en plus c'est l'histoire
entre le père et le fils et c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas été traité par
ailleurs et c'est vraiment un très bon
film si tard dit c'est très bien c'est
toujours très bien ce qui fait très
agréable les voies étaient très
intéressante notamment jean rochefort
très drôle j'avais déjà vu de films de
cuisine aussi mais je fais c'est un truc
à l'américaine donc c'est à dire qu'ils
savent faire mais comment dire les
cuisiniers ils vont dévorer cela je
pense
c'était assez représentatifs de la
cuisine sont nés du milieu donc voilà on
apprécié il ya de l'humour il ya de la
tendresse
il ya de l'émotion dans entend relayer
des répliques qui sont drôles amusante
et malgré tout ça reste un film très
sensible et plein d'émotion sublimé m'a
beaucoup plu et je vais en profiter pour
leur commander plusieurs personnes parce
que vraiment il est remarquable
la bande annonce c'est ce format très
court qui en général vous incite à aller
au cinéma c'est aussi un genre à part
entière et le thème du festival béaba la
première édition se tient ce week-end à
bois d'arcy
le festival sera notamment présentée par
vincent perrot un animateur télévisée
jean-philippe luce était l'invité de
notre émission culturelle crasc mercredi
4 novembre ou l'écoutent
pourquoi la bande-annonce parce qu'en
fait la bande annonce c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas traitée ou très peu traité au
niveau national il n'existe pas de
festival sur cette thématique là et
c'est une thématique assez important
puisqu'en fait sans la bande annonce on
n'a pas forcément envie d'aller au
cinéma c'est c'est le premier pas vers
le film c'est ce qui nous attire qui
nous donne envie ou pas d'y aller
vous pouvez retrouver l'intégralité de
cet entretien sur notre site internet
alors pour ceux qui voudrait consacrer
leur week-end au sport ce dimanche c'est
la troisième édition de la course royal
nous voir nous a rejoint au plateau
philippe grenier qui est adjoint au
maire délégué aux sports de fontenay le
fleury
bonjour le départ sera donné dimanche à
10 heures de la pièce d'eau des suisses
à versailles quel est le parcours de
cette course royal alors le parcours oui
comme vous le dites c'est à la pièce
d'eau des suisses à la devant la statue
du louis xiv qui suivra ensuite l'allée
des mortemets de la led est morte mais
nous allons rentrer dans le
que du château de versailles très beau
moment pour les pour les coureurs et
ensuite nous allons rentrer sur la
plaine de versailles pour continuer dans
tout ce qui est plein de versailles et
retour sur fontaine fleurie au gymnase
descartes où sera l'arrivée
donc en fait vous alliez paysages
magnifiques de la plaine de versailles
et intérêts sportifs tout à fait plus
voilà les coureurs viennent peut-être
pas pour la performance mais également
pour comment pour la beauté du paysage
qui est quand même au patrimoine de
l'unesco de plaine de versailles château
de versailles
et voilà ils viennent beaucoup moins
pour la performance c'est la troisième
édition la dir général vous avez du
monde la première édition 2 113 coureurs
la deuxième édition nous étions à 510
coureurs et à ce jour nous sommes à 560
participants
gl performance justement ça dimanche en
terme d'inscriptions c'est encore
possible jusqu'à demain au gymnase
descartes à gino comment la fontaine
fleurie de 14 heures à 17 heures voilà
des inscriptions en direct mais il ya
plusieurs parcours
tout le monde ne fait pas la même chose
un parcours de 10 km deuxième parcours
de 20 km une marche dans dick devynck de
10 km pardon et cette année une petite
course enfants pour les enfants de 9 10
ans de 2 km il ya aussi une
particularité toujours avec les enfants
ce test vous avez été contacté par dunes
d'espoir voilà tout à fait l'association
dunes d'espoir qui est association avec
des enfants handicapés m'ont contacté
pour pouvoir participer à la course
cette année il y aura trois enfants en
geôle est qu'ils seront accompagnés de
coureurs deux enfants vont faire le 20
km une chose est sûre le 10 km voilà
c'est une belle expérience pour eux et
voilà les les coureurs ne manqueront pas
les applaudir à leur passage
c'est important c'est pour vous de faire
participer les enfants tout à fait c'est
une belle initiative c'est beau c'est
voilà c'est de voir leur sourire quand
ils vont arriver sur la ligne d'arrivée
voilà je trouve ça magnifique et vous
pensez à l'affairé l'expérience bien sûr
j'espère alors merci philippe grenier
pour toutes ces précisions pour ce qui
serait donc tenté par la course royal
vous pouvez toujours vous inscrire le
départ je le répète sera donné à
6 heures ce dimanche on termine notre
7,8 week-end avec le concours photo
après les couleurs d'automne à nouveau
thème vous sera proposé écouter claude
chose le président de l'union régionale
de la photographie le prochain thème et
bien écoutez toujours sur le local
puisque c'est notre c'est le but de
notre dans notre intervention sur tv fil
c'est votre regard sur votre ville donc
les photos seront toujours à déposer
donc sur l'adresse rédaction @ défilent
point com est la date limite de dépôt
des photos c'est pour le 12 novembre
donc à vos appareils
à l'heure actuelle vous avez de très
belles lumières profitez-en pour sortir
pour montrer l'intérêt que vous avez
pour votre ville
le sachet ce week-end est terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous donne rendez-vous à la semaine
prochaine pour trouver encore des idées
sorties et loisirs
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end